مجزره في كاليفورنيا عشره قتلى ومثلهم
مصابون بعمليه اطلاق نار 100 الف
اسرائيليه تظاهرون ضد حكومه نتنياهو مدافن
صديقه للبيئه الجثه تتحول الى سماد زراعيه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها منقولها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
البدايه من ولايه كاليفورنيا حيث افادت
الشرطه الامريكيه بمقتل 10 اشخاص واصابه
10 اخرين في حادث اطلاق نار قرب احتفال
بالعام القمري الصيني الجديد الذي شارك
فيه عشرات الالاف بمدينه مونتري بارك في
مقاطعه لوس انجلوس وقالت الشرطه الامريكيه
ان المشتبه به في تنفيذ حادث اطلاق النار
الجماعي مازال طليقا في ما لم تكشف حتى
الان الدوافع وراء الحادث وتعد مونتري
بارك الواقعه على مسافه نحو 13 كيلو مترا
شرق وسط
الاسيويين في امريكا
وفي اسرائيل خرج نحو مئه الف متظاهر في
وسط تل ابيب اعتراضا على حكومه رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو في
واحده من اكبر الاحتجاجات في البلاد منذ
نحو عشره اعوام ويعترض المتظاهرون على خطه
الحكومه اليمنيه الجديده للحد من سلطات
القضاء وسط مخاوف من ان يقوض ذلك
الديمقراطيه وكانت الاصلاحات القضائيه
المقترحه في اسرائيل اثارت انتقادات عده
من قبل رئيسه المحكمه الدستوريه العليا في
ما وصف نتنياه المشاركين بالاحتجاجات
بانهم يتحدون اراده الناخبين
وفي خطوه اعتبرها البعض صديقه للبيئه
مقبره في مدينه نيويورك الامريكيه تحول
جثث الموتى الى سماد للزراعه بدلا من
دفنها بشكل تقليدي وتهدف طريقه تسميد
البشري الى خلق طرق للدفن صديقه للبيئه
حيث توفر اكثر من طن من الكربون مقارنه
بالدفن التقليدي او حرق الجثث وتوضع جثه
الميت في وعاء مغلق محاط بمواد طبيعيه مثل
رقائق الخشب والبرسيم ما يسمح بانتاجها
الميكروبات خاصه لتحليلها خلال ثلاثين
يوما ومن ثم يعطى الرفات لاقارب الميت
لنثرها على النباتات والاشجار
وفي خبرنا التالي طمان نجم مارفل
جيرميرانر جمهوره عبر رساله من داخل
المستشفى بعد الحادث الماسوي الذي تعرض له
في يوم راس السنه عندما انقلبت عليه كاسحه
ثلوج تزن نحو سته اطنان الممثل الامريكي
اكد تعرضه لكسر في 30 عظمه مع خضوعه
لعمليتين جرايتين جراء الحادث وقد نشرت
تدريبات صباحيه يؤديها خلال الاستلقاء على
سرير المستشفى مؤكدا لمحبيه انه سيتعافى
وسيصبح اقوى
وفي خبرنا الاخير احتضنت العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض كوكبه من نجوم السينما العالميه
والعربيه خلال فعاليات توزيع جوائز جوي
اورد 213
وشهدت الدوره الثالثه من الحفل اعلن جائزه
جديده تحمل اسم صناع الترفيه الماسيه
والتي نالها رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي
سي وليد ال ابراهيم كما كرم الحفل
الفنانين عالميين وعربا بجوائز متنوعه بين
فخريه خاصه بصناعه الترفيه واخرى عن
الانجاز مدى الحياه وشخصيات العام ولم
يغفل كذلك الحفل النجوم الراحل
[موسيقى]